hi guys my name is Portia and I'm a
makeup artist and an influencer and
today I'm going to be creating I do like
to look for you guys it's basically been
on trend all year you can wear it at any
point of the year and it's my absolute
go to if you want to see how to create
this look keep on watching first step
I'm going to be prepping my skin and I'm
going to use cover FX basically just put
it in two different areas where your
face is going to be creasing so like
smile lines around your eyes and then
I'm going to be using a moisturizer it's
not particularly oily I don't want too
much oil to start loading up on your
face because obviously this is quite a
jewelry look if you face a little
massage the next thing I'm going to be
doing is going to be foundation I
usually use one two two sometimes even
three different colors just because then
you can get kind of like a lighter color
here and a lighter color here and just
darken here for the lighter foundation I
use the ordinary and it's a serum
foundation it sits on your skin really
lovely and then for the darker shades I
used three ena and that's a three-in-one
foundation you just start by putting a
lighter color like underneath the eyes
because it kind of helps me to figure
out how I want it I want to look like
I'm lit from within I'm just going to be
adding a little bit of highlighter drops
by Barry M and that's just going to help
to just create a foundation of like GE
nurse just put it on that one area that
you want to really attract like - so
next I'm going to do the eyebrows so I'm
just going to be filling in the areas
that look a little bit sparse and just
trying to make it look a little bit
thicker next I'm going to be doing the
eyes first I'm going to kind of lay down
the foundation for that I'm going to use
a product called pure and then I'm going
to be using a fancy Beauty it's kind of
like a multi-use highlighter I mean it's
a little bit pinky that'll really like
make it pop but it will still look
natural
just to bronze up a little bit more I'm
going to be using a three inner eye
pencil just to kind of create a little
bit more of like a bronzy area around
here and then I'm going to use a try
blend highlighter which has been very M
just to make that area of my eyes pop as
well I'm just gonna put this pencil from
my inner eye to my outside eye along the
top lash line just to make it pop a
little bit more to hold them as far I'm
going to use a black mascara and it's an
extra lengthening black mascara and it's
by Barry era it's called showgirl I'm
going to be using a little wand so what
I do is I put it into the product and
whiz it around and when you want it to
be quite natural and have quite a
controlled amount of mascara
it really helps so a little tip I'm just
going to use a little bit of lip gloss
it's gonna be clear lip gloss and I'm
just gonna dab it on sort of like my
brow bone and over a little bit of my
eye just so it's quite Julie on my
eyelids as well so now I'm going to go
into lips I'm gonna start off with a lip
liner I've gone quite close to my
natural lip color because you don't want
to look like you're putting much effort
at all into this look I'm going to go on
to apply a kind of ruby red color lip
gloss that should make it all nice and
shimmery next I'm going to be applying a
cream blusher and the brand I'm using is
C arte London and I'm just going to
apply it with my fingers to the ampulla
the cheeks and then blend it in
and then I'm going to go on to contour
my face quite naturally but with that
same pure product the golden dark tone
that I used as the foundation based on
my eyes we just want to apply the last
finishing touches of the juin s to the
dewy look and we're going to be using
the Kryolan illusion palette and I'm
just basically going to be applying it
to ample of my cheeks again maybe just
above my lip along my nose I'm just
actually going to add a little bit more
of the lip gloss that I added to my eyes
onto my cheeks this is lovely but it's
quite subtle so it can always just add a
little bit
[Music]
so I hope you guys really enjoyed my do
lighter look perfect for any time of the
year one of my favorite looks ever if
you did really liked it please comment
and share below and also head over to
Glamour UK for more videos like this
[Music]